ils sont là les castors guerre montréal
chantal hébert vous êtes à toronto
michel ces ogm montréal également
bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir bonsoir
en vain nouveau venu dans la campagne
conservatrice on va voir sa photo
totalement inconnu pour vous mesdames et
messieurs ne vous en faites pas c'est
normal il s'appelle hinton crosby c'est
un organisateur politique hors pair qui
a aidé récemment à david cameron en
grande bretagne à se faire réélire
il est australien et s la roue de
secours ont en tout cas un appel de
détresse qui a été entendu je ne sais
pas entrés ils arrivent dans la campagne
conservatrice de monsieur un peu chantal
hébert qu'est ce que ça nous dit c'est
assez extraordinaire est assez inusité
jeu ça dit trois choses la première
c'est l'évidence là monsieur sens bien
aidé
les conservateurs avec leurs messages en
autres mots le message la campagne
conservatrice sortait pas on fait pas
venir quelqu'un de l'étranger comme ça
quand tout va bien comme dans le
meilleur des mondes
la deuxième chose qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'avec toute l'expertisé en
campagne électorale qu'il y as au canada
dans les officines conservatrice c'est
quand même spécial d'aller chercher
quelqu'un qui a travaillé à l'étranger
la troisième c'est une remarque
quelqu'un
un analyste politique faisait sur un
film britannique
ce monsieur ya passé deux ans et demi à
préparer la campagne de david cameron là
c'est pas juste nous qui le connaissons
pas où les gens qui regardent la télé
c'est les gens de l'équipe conservatrice
avec laquelle il va travailler et michel
jauger dans une réputation je le disais
il est pour les maniaques de politique
c'est un c'est un général c'est
quelqu'un qui aime organiser mais il
reste il ne lui reste que 38 jours au
canada
c'est ça j'entendais 23 au point moi
aussi je trouve au point ce n'est pas la
première fois que ça arrive deuxièmement
c'est toujours un signe de panique puis
troisièmement ça marche pas souvent ces
affaires là et surtout quand on a
quelqu'un qui arrive qu'ils n'arrivent
cependant puisqu'elle gamins du parti
conservateur de l'ontario
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive de loin c'est
quelqu'un qui est pas nécessairement
habitués ni au premier ministre ni à la
façon de procéder
alors j'imagine que c'est quelqu'un de
très très grande qualité effectivement
si on lisait politiques britanniques
sont en anglais je n'ai vu quelques fois
mentionné comme un des grands bacs en
bois et là ça veut pas dire que la grève
va prendre alec un mot là-dessus
ouais ben il est aussi australiens faut
pas l'oublier on parle de david cameron
qui est sa dernière affectation mais le
travail est beaucoup avec le
gouvernement libéral qui est en fait un
gouvernement conservateur en australie
donc et il stephen empereur s'inspire
beaucoup de l'australie depuis qu'il est
au pouvoir il ya beaucoup de mesures qui
ont été proposées au canada qui viennent
de ce qui a été tenté par les
conservateurs en australie donc il
connaît certainement une partie de ce
que les conservateurs veulent faire
comme message vais le passer comme
message parce que la grève va prendre un
si court terme
j'entends la véraison dit que le travail
avec david cameron pendant des mois
voire des années
l'une de ces stratégies d'ailleurs
c'était d'aller chercher toutes les
communautés ethniques en angleterre
c'est ce que j'essaye kenny a fait ici
ce travail là était appliquée à longue
haleine mais pour l'instant c'est parce
qu'ils semblent fonctionner dans la
campagne conservatrice qui plutôt
effectivement en difficulté j'ai hâte de
voir si effectivement ça va donner
quelque chose avant le 19 octobre pour
trouver c'est une arrivée quand on
marque parce que c'est quand même pas
c'est pas banal
je veux vous faire entendre stephen
harper aujourd'hui on a entendu un peu
plus tôt mairie couteau le appelons ça
un recentrage
ça j'en écoute et je ne discute pas des
des questions de de staffing
mais évidemment j'ai une bonne équipe ce
n'était pas le bon extraits que je
voulais y faisait référence à ceux dont
on vient de parler je sais pas sur le
l'extrait sur le les migrants on va
l'écouter sur un chanceux qui auraient
alors cédé nuage vous allez me dire
chantal mais on sent quand même un
changement de discours de monsieur alors
il ya une semaine jour pour jour
monsieur harper avait une chance de
sauter et de prendre les devants du
défilé et aujourd'hui ils embarquent
dans le défilé par ce qui est en train
de se faire piétiner par les gens qui
marchent et parmi les gens qui le
piétine
il ya des gens qui seront pas que les
conservateurs sont pas taille à
affronter entre autres l'ancien chef de
la défense weekly le général à la
retraite qui a commencé à faire le tour
des plateaux de télévision pour
expliquer que les craintes de sécurité
c'est un prétexte et que c'était
faisable de fermer beaucoup plus de gens
et qu'il fallait le faire aujourd'hui
jean charest donc monsieur harper a plus
le choix on verra de quelle mesure il
accouchera et ce sera jugé satisfaisant
mais l'occasion de rendez vous manqués
ça ça se récupère papa alec castonguay
skull un nouveau stratège et un nouveau
discours
est ce que tout ça on repart à zéro la
machine dont dur commence
ça existe rarement campagne électorale
de remettre le compteur à zéro il se
passe tellement de choses et les
impressions sans que chez les électeurs
est là après cinq semaines de difficiles
campagne pour stephen harper est-ce
qu'on peut redresser le
à berck probablement qu'on va essayer
est ce qu'on est capable de faire table
rase de tout ce qui s'est passé quand
elle disait ça fait une semaine que
steven empereur et dû agir sur la crise
des réfugiés
les mecs vaudrait mieux vaut tard que
jamais mais l'impression que ça va
laisser ses qui est obligé de bouger que
ce n'est pas lui qui le fait de gaieté
dans l'électorat je pense en tant que ça
laisse une très bonne impression dont
vous pourrez sur une chose les images il
a manqué le test de l'empathie la
semaine dernière et le nouveau test ça
va être des détails or le diable
toujours dans le détail il faut savoir
des tanks sommes sur un peu de dire
alors ouvrir un petit peu plus la porte
j'avais remarqué les réactions fort
différentes dont je dis extensible ce
sujet là je relance mais allonge et très
rapidement mais ce trudeau première
réaction aujourd'hui il a dit ben ben
tant mieux c'est une bonne chose
et de l'autre côté le mal qu est
beaucoup plus agressif en dix ans mais
voyons dont il aurait pu le faire plus
tôt qu'est ce que ça vous dit ça sur sur
ces deux chefs chantal que parfois
monsieur marc et demeure le chef de
l'opposition qui s'en va la période des
questions et que dans ce cas ci je pense
que la réaction peut être plus
politiquement s'agace c'était celle de
monsieur trudeau qui est de dire enfin
il fait la bonne chose est de montrer
quelques parcs l'opposition à compter
des points là dedans et de passer à
autre chose très bien à la question gay
on va vous faire écouter je voulais en
parler je crois un extrait d'une
entrevue que monsieur trudeau a donné a
affirmé ce bridge de la sib ici avec une
réaction assez vives du premier min sur
les coudes simple on vient vous quand on
part d
copé de faire comme sa part des
agriculteurs des des pêcheurs ici dans
l'est de france à voir des personnes
comme des artistes graphiques prendre
beaucoup de temps des travailleurs
autonomes de dire que ces gens sont des
riches qui avaient des taxes et des
impôts
c'est incroyable ce n'est pas juste pour
notre parti on ne veut pas une guerre de
taxes contre les propriétaires des
petites - entreprises alors à la
question gay on a vu un monsieur trudeau
il y avait la traduction est ce une
gaffe que d'avoir eu l'impression de
dire que les pme un gars des trous dans
les poches
mais pour remettre en contexte le peter
mansbridge demandait juste être docile
et est d'accord avec la position du npd
parti conservateur de baisser les impôts
des pme de 11 à 9 %
il dit oui je suis d'accord livre est
arrivé avec cette réponse là une large
proportion de ces pme locke qui servent
en réalité de paravent ou d'outils pour
les plus riches pour baisser leurs
impôts y applaudit en eau qui existait
faut faire attention revenu canada
travaille là dessus pour effectivement
que ça soit pas des véhicules vides qui
permettent aux canadiens de le plus
épuré d'éluder l'impôt il dit une large
proportion
il ya beaucoup de propriétaires de pme
c'est quand même large partie de la
création d'emplois au canada qui vient
des pme qui vont se dire je suis pas
certain et la queue juste un être doux
comprend la réalité que moi je vis comme
propriétaires de pme j'ai situé 10
employés ou j'essaie d'arriver et
lorsqu'il dissèque moi je me sers de mon
entreprise pour payer moins d'impôts je
suis pas certain que le message était
tout à fait un rapport il faudrait qu'il
faudra envoyer comme message rapidement
chantal et michel la tuque vous avez une
autre sujet d'abord il ya un certain
nombre d'économistes l'inspecteur jack
mintz pour pas le nommer qui vont vous
démontrer avec chiffres à l'appui qu'une
proportion importante du 1 % les gens
qui gagnent le plus
ça fait partie de leur stratégie fiscale
que de se former des corporations pour
payer moins d'impôts et quand justin
trudeau zee des sages justement à faire
il ya du bon côté d'un grand nombre
d'économistes
très bien ça manquerait quand même un
petit peu d'empathie pour les gens qui
vivent ce qu'ils sont des vrais
propriétaires de deux pme et qui ont de
la difficulté c'est vrai qu'il ya des
gens qui s'enregistrent pour pouvoir
déduire la voiture et cetera et cetera
mais ça s'arrange
de façon très simple dans la loi de
l'épreuve très simple peut-être pas mais
simple de façon facile dans la loi de
l'impôt si on le veut suffit d'avoir la
volonté politique y avait juste à dire
ça oui king là c'est ça que ça veut dire
ça veut dire faire des ajustements
oui je cherchais un mot sur le npd qui
appuient le npd qui appuie jean perret
le le cas puis le rayon la ftq est ce
que je vais le dire
la ftq qui a pu mpd saguenay entre
autres qu'est ce que ça nous dit sur la
campagne du bloc québécois
ben ça nous dit que vous ne savez au
début de la campagne la ftq avait dit on
va puis les candidats les plus
susceptibles n'y avait pas choisi le
parti de bart les conservateurs et là il
n'ya pas de bloquistes dans la liste et
ça nous disent qu'on voit dans les
sondages que la campagne du bloc dans le
moment donne dans les projections siège
de 0 à 2 sièges et celle ci la ftq est
une grosse organisation qui a des
oreilles par terre un peu partout au
québec
ils savent quel est le coût des gens
parce que ils sont tellement une grosse
organisation qu'ils ont des sections
locales partout dans toutes les régions
puis il sent qu'il se passe au québec
actuellement à 4 la ftq avant même le
début de la campagne électorale dit
écoutez nous n'avons pas donné notre
prix officiel au bloc québécois comme on
l'avait fait d'habitude et on va dire de
battre les conservateurs
il savait que ses soeurs que leurs
membres et que beaucoup beaucoup de
québécois penser ce qu'on s'occupe seule
de notre reportage au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean du monde c'est
exactement ça on va le voir un peu plus
tard well in tune crosby est ce que ça
existe pour le bloc québécois allaient
qu'en terminant l'émirat qui sont plus
difficiles à réaliser d'autres pour le
bloc québécois je pense que ça va être
difficile ce qui est intéressant dans ce
que la ftq annoncé c'est pourtant le
fait qu'ils vont nous appuyer le npd
dans ces circonscriptions là parce que
la capacité de mobilisation des
syndicats devenus avec le temps c'est le
travail de terrain qu'ils vont faire on
dit que 10000 syndiqués de la ftq dans
chacune des circonscriptions qu'on a
annoncé aujourd'hui où on va appuyer le
npd ce samedi des gens qu'on va
rejoindre par courriel par téléphone
qu'on veut capable de convaincre de ne
pas voter pour le parti conservateur est
depuis les [ __ ] donc c'est pourtant
l'annoncé officielle publique qui est
utile
le npd comme lebron l'huile de bras qui
arrivent sur le terrain pour parler ses
10000 personnes là dix mille personnes
dans une circonscription comprend le
taux de participation
ça peut faire la différence à la fin
voilà merci à vous trois on va trop
merci au revoir